on this Tuesday night Hockey Canada
cleans house its CEO and entire board
gone we wanted to see meaningful change
we've seen meaningful change what
happens next and how the culture needs
to change recession projection a grim
new Financial forecast and what the
international monetary fund says could
cushion the blow emergency talks on
Ukraine The g7s Pledge and the new
health Canada is deploying plus she was
one of the last surviving stars of the
golden age of Hollywood or one of you
adolescents please tell me what's
happened remembering the long career of
Angela Lansbury
foreign
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
after weeks of political and corporate
pressure Hockey Canada is overhauling
its entire senior leadership team its
CEO Scott Smith is out and the full
board of directors has agreed to step
aside in a statement Hockey Canada says
an interim management committee will be
put in place which will guide the
organization until no later than a newly
constituted board appoints a new CEO to
lead the organization the calls for a
shake-up have been persistent and Loud
including from the Prime Minister who
has said repeatedly only new leadership
can change the culture of the
organization which has been widely
condemned for the way it handled
allegations of sexual assault
there's a culture to change there is an
awful lot of work to ensure that the
structures and systems that Hockey
Canada has in place protects employees
protects Canadians protects our kids as
they play hockey there's work to do to
transform the culture at Hockey Canada
but today was an important first step
changing the culture restoring faith in
the organization will take time Mike
drolet now on what lies ahead for Hockey
Canada
under withering pressure from Grassroots
organizations all the way up to the
prime minister's office Hockey Canada
found itself with few allies and fewer
options so the entire board including
CEO Scott Smith resigned starting today
we're going to work with the
organization to rebuild it and to make
sure that the new leadership is going to
have the same motivation that we have
the news was met with Relief by the
mayors of Halifax and Moncton who as
co-hosts of the world juniors in
December were excited to host a hockey
tournament not field questions about
Hockey Canada's mishandling and cover-up
of an alleged sexual assault that
occurred in 2018. we're planning to host
the World Juniors we haven't pulled out
we don't intend to pull out we wanted to
see meaningful change we've seen
meaningful change the national governing
body for the sport has been under
intense scrutiny since first appearing
before a House of Commons Committee in
June as recently as last week Hockey
Canada had dug in its heels with interim
chair Andrea Skinner going so far far as
to question how hockey could continue
without them will the lights stay on on
the rink I don't know the reaction to
Skinner's comments was Swift one after
another provincial hockey federations
stepped away and the sponsor Exodus saw
Major Brands officially pull their
support the Ontario Hockey Federation
released a statement saying it cannot be
understated that trust needs to be
rebuilt with Canadians on and off the
ice Brands like Hockey Canada are not
who Hockey Canada says they are it's who
we as consumers who we as the people who
play the game say they are a new board
will be elected in December which will
in turn appoint a new CEO who will have
his or her hands full sports management
expert Ann pegararo says it could take
years to rebuild the brand which is
secondary to addressing the toxic
culture that permeates within the sport
you know we spent a lot of time teaching
young women how not to put themselves
into harmful situations I think it's
starting time we start teaching young
men how not to do harm and build that
from the beginning the culture of hockey
needs significant change there's only
one place to start at the Grassroots
microwave Global News Toronto
there is renewed support for Ukraine
from leaders of some of the world's
richest Nations G7 leaders met virtually
with the president of Ukraine today
promising to back him for as long as it
takes Vladimir zielinski is asking for
better air defense support to counter
missiles and drones after Russia
launched a fresh round of deadly strikes
on civilian targets and key
infrastructure more International Help
is coming including from Canada but as
Crystal gemancing Reports it may not be
what Ukraine needs most
Russian missile strikes knocked out four
electrical substations in leviv two are
completely destroyed leaving people once
again in the dark this time about 30
percent of the city is without power and
that's having a ripple effect on water
supplies and cell service
on the other side of the country more
signs of Destruction and death at least
five were killed Tuesday in a series of
Rocket attacks in zaparizia officials
say a school medical facility and a car
dealership were hit
it was loud things were flying over here
I rushed to the hallway children were
crying
ukrainians have endured 230 days of
shelling and tears
Russia must be completely isolated and
punished Vladimir zielinski told G7
leaders in a virtual meeting the
Ukrainian president's number one ask was
for Effective and modern air defense
systems G7 leaders pledged military
financial and humanitarian support for
as long as it takes Canada's minister of
National Defense offered up More Than
Just Words of support
Canada will deploy approximately 40
combat engineers to Poland to help
polish forces train Ukrainian stoppers
on engineer reconnaissance explosives
Mining and demining Monday's attacks are
the largest series of strikes away from
the front lines since the start of the
invasion in February the costs to Russia
in people and Equipment are staggering
and we know and Russian military
commanders know
that their supplies and munition are
running out the UK's spy Chief says
Putin has misjudged this situation and
suffered multiple strategic failures
from Russia nothing but a show of force
new defense videos show off cruise
missile launches and on-site training
inspections of recently mobilized troops
Ukraine has reclaimed large swaths of
territory in recent weeks but people are
back to spending hours underground
knowing their safety is not guaranteed
anywhere in the country
Crystal commencing Global News London
a Canadian government delegation is
visiting Taiwan ignoring China's warning
to stay away the cross party group
landed Sunday and attended taiwan's
National Day Celebrations and met with
the country's leaders Taiwan is under
increased military and political
pressure from China Beijing claims
Taiwan as its own territory and has said
it will take forceful measures if Ottawa
interferes as Abigail Beeman reports
Canada isn't the only country showing
support for Taiwan
a number of nations on hand to show
support at taiwan's national day
including a Canadian parliamentary
delegation of five cross-party MPS what
they're trying to do is in this
particularly tense moment
after these military exercises in August
that they see it as being very important
that the International Community show
their support
for Taiwan August following a high
profile visit by U.S Secretary of State
Nancy Pelosi Chinese airships and
warships rehearsed an attack on the
island crossing the median line in the
Taiwan Strait it looks like they're
preparing for an action to Annex Taiwan
into the People's Republic of China
taiwan's president said war between
China and Taiwan was absolutely not an
option reiterating her willingness to
talk to Beijing while China blames
taiwan's push for Independence for all
problems in the strait a number of other
countries have sent delegations to
Taiwan since August experts say Canada
has a number of issues to talk about
this visit on investment culture and
trade specifically taiwan's interest in
joining the comprehensive and
Progressive agreement for trans-pacific
partnership or cptpp as well as
closed-door discussions on security many
indo-pacific analysts point to a
strengthening of Canada's presence in
the region top of the the list new
ambassador to China Jennifer May and a
new representative in Taiwan respected
Diplomat Jim Nichol this is very
appropriate because we're going to have
an indo-pacific strategy announced soon
and it will be important that Taiwan is
part of it when the Prime Minister was
asked about the potential Canadian visit
back in the summer he stopped short of a
clear endorsement we will ensure that
the parliamentarians making the decision
to travel or not will be done with all
the reflections of the consequences and
the impacts of it with no move or
decisions simple in that region but
coordinated international support key in
the face of China Abigail Beeman Global
News
Ottawa
throwing threats from China and Russia
are creating deeper alliances between
Canada and Japan the foreign ministers
from Canada and Japan met in Tokyo to
discuss plans to boost security
cooperation and Military Intelligence
sharing including holding joint military
exercises both sides say Russia's war in
Ukraine is having serious and enormous
repercussions for the world they also
want a free and open indo-pacific region
China has been escalating its presence
in the East and South China Seas
Canada's foreign affairs minister
Melanie Jolie calls that an unacceptable
threat to Regional stability and
security Japan has similar intelligence
sharing agreements with eight other
countries including the United States
well there is a new and not very
optimistic forecast from the
international monetary fund about the
world economy it has slashed its
forecast for economic growth we know the
soaring cost of living is already
causing strain on so many people
including Canadians well now the
international monetary fund is warning
the worst is yet to come and gavioli
explains what's coming and why the
measures to prevent a recession could
end up causing one
a chilling forecast in the imf's
economic World Outlook winter 2022 will
be challenging but winter 2023 will
likely be worse the World Bank and the
IMF warn next year will feel like a
recession after a series of
unprecedented economic shocks and risks
25 probability Global growth next year
could slow down to below two percent a
historically low level we've only had
that five times since 1970. topping the
list of imminent risks to the global
economy are an escalation of the war
raging in Ukraine the increasing toll of
climate disasters including this
historic and devastating Atlantic
hurricane season and catastrophic
flooding in Pakistan along with Rising
interest rates and inflation
in fact rapidly Rising food prices and
the High Cost of Living which countries
all around the world are struggling with
are key concerns maybe a recession is
the smaller price to pay history shows
that not acting swiftly and meaningfully
to tame inflation creates a more costly
mess down the road in the 70s the Bank
of Canada was slow to raise interest
rates and the cost of living skyrocketed
at one point in the 80s rates were as
high as 21 percent in a bid to cool
rampant inflation under tightening would
further entrench the inflation process
erode The credibility of central banks
and de-anchor inflation expectations the
forecast is that the three largest
economies in the world the U.S China and
the Eurozone will stall Canada won't be
immune Canada is definitely sensitive to
what's going on in the rest of the world
of course we're most
intertwined with the U.S economy to
create a buffer against future shocks
the IMF recommends governments invest in
the digital economy human capital green
energy and supply chain diversification
for now though interest rates need to go
higher and governments are urged to send
targeted support to low-income
households because an economic winter is
coming and gaviola Global News Toronto
a sentencing hearing is underway in BC
for a Dutch man in a high-profile
extortion case coming up what his
victim's mother is hoping will be the
outcome
in BC the sentencing hearing in a
high-profile sex extortion case is
underway It Centers on the tragic story
of Amanda Todd she died by suicide in
2012 after being tormented online for
three years a Dutch man Iden koban was
found guilty of several offenses related
to harassment and extortion and
prosecutors recommend he spent 12 years
in jail nithu Garcia spoke with Amanda
Todd's mother today about the emotional
toll this long legal process is taking
Amanda Todd's mother arrives at BC
Supreme Court for the postponed
sentencing hearing the timing she says
is notable a day after the 10-year
anniversary of when her 15 year old
daughter died by Suicide which is also
World mental health day we need to make
sure there's there's Justice for Amanda
so that the the wheels are rolling for
other countries that they can they can
stop these Predators I didn't co-ban
with his back to the gallery where
Todd's family including her mother and
brother sat was convicted in August on
charges of extortion possession and
distribution of child pornography child
luring and harassment he was extradited
from the Netherlands to Canada in 2020
after being convicted of similar charges
involving dozens of young girls and gay
men in Amsterdam his defense lawyer has
previously said there was no question
Todd was the victim of crimes but the
evidence did not prove his client was
the online extortionist the lead Crown
prosecutor in is now arguing for a
12-year sentence applying to all charges
consecutive to the nearly 11-year Dutch
sentence he's currently serving Crown
also told the court the offenses he
committed were morally repugnant his
conduct was calculated callous and had
devastating consequences adding evidence
demonstrates he is unrepentant he has
been in custody for many similar
offenses since January 2014 and has
shown no interest in rehabilitation
the video Todd posted became part of a
global movement for online child safety
the judge's decision is expected by the
end of this week but what happens with
that sentence we don't know and it has
to go through the court system in the
Netherlands for conversion if he doesn't
get any prison time because of a
conversion
that would upset me unique legal
circumstances which this mother turned
Internet safety and mental health
Advocate hopes will set an international
precedent Garcia Global News New
Westminster BC
ahead Western discontent simmers in
Saskatchewan and Alberta is it a sign of
a looming constitutional crisis
Buckingham Palace has announced the
coronation of King Charles III will take
place on Saturday May 6 at Westminster
Abbey the king and queen consort were in
Scotland today thanking those who helped
organize the final journey of Queen
Elizabeth II The King's coronation is
expected to be rooted in Tradition but
with the pageantry toned down to reflect
the times and conform with the king's
desire for a slim down monarchy
Saskatchewan's Premiere is pushing back
on what he calls Federal interference in
his Province Scott Moe is prepared to
bring a new legislation this fall it
will help Saskatchewan stand up to
Ottawa that sentiment Echoes the
campaign promise of the new Alberta
Premier raising concerns that with
tensions with Ottawa Rising Canada could
slowly be heading towards a
constitutional crisis Heather York's
West explains we look ahead in
Saskatchewan Saskatchewan Premier Scott
Moe says his province has had enough we
want to develop more of those resources
we want to develop more potash mines in
Saskatchewan we want to develop more
uranium mines in Saskatchewan we want to
further develop the energy industry but
he says nine Federal climate policies
are standing in the way accusing Ottawa
of overstepping into provincial
jurisdiction Moe says they will
introduce legislation this fall to
reassert their constitutional rights
Moe's policy paper is just the latest in
a series of moves challenging Federal
jurisdiction it comes after Alberta
Saskatchewan and Manitoba all said they
would not be enforcing a federal gun
buyback program Alberta's new premier is
vowing to push ahead with her so-called
Alberta sovereignty act while Quebec's
Bill 96 on French language rights has
made actual changes to Canada's
Constitution through a little known
provision there's no question that we're
in a period of rising tensions which law
professor Eric Adams believes could lead
to a constitutional crisis if not taken
seriously both Alberta and Saskatchewan
Premier say they'd like their provinces
to be more independent like Quebec
that's a political Choice that's open to
the provincial government the great
legislative challenge I think of our
times is uh
dealing with the climate crisis and
different uh political parties want to
approach that problem in very different
ways the moves against Ottawa in the
Prairies are politically popular ISO
affirm after being sworn in as Alberta's
Premier Tuesday Danielle Smith affirmed
that was Priority One together we will
stand up to defend Al Burton's Charter
rights as well as defense Alberta's
exclusive rights over our areas of
provincial jurisdiction the province of
Alberta can't simply opt out of federal
laws willy-nilly begging questions about
what real benefit Smith's Alberta
sovereignty act can bring as the federal
government deals with more Western
discontent Heather urich's West Global
News Calgary
next she was known in later years for
Murder She Wrote but Angela Lansbury's
Talent extended well beyond that
a big claim from NASA today it says it
is proven it can defend planet Earth
from asteroid strikes NASA says its dark
probe which crashed into the asteroid
dimorphous last month did alter the
orbit of that asteroid which means it's
possible to nudge an asteroid off course
potentially allowing humans to defend
the Earth from threatening objects
before the Collision dimorphous orbited
its larger parent asteroid once every 11
hours and 55 minutes now each orbit is
32 minutes shorter triple what NASA had
expected
well there aren't many actors who can
claim triumphs on the stage in musical
theater in Hollywood movies and on TV
Angela Lansbury did it all those who
worked with her say it was her
intelligence her integrity and her
warmth that Shone through in every role
Lansbury who graced our screens for more
than seven decades passed away today
just five days shy of her 97th birthday
Eric Sorensen looks back at her
illustrious career
goodbye little yellow bird her acting
career was as long as it was
distinguished her greatest Acclaim came
on stage a five-time Tony Award winner
here as the pie maker in the murder
musical Sweeney Todd
born in England her family moved to the
U.S in 1940 to escape the war in Europe
Lansbury found stardom in Hollywood at a
young age here as sister to Elizabeth
Taylor
[Music]
later a witch on bed knobs and
Broomsticks she loved acting I play an
absolutely outlandishly funny character
couldn't ask for more among her honors
was Dame commander of the British Empire
and a Lifetime Achievement Award in film
to younger Generations she was perhaps
best known from television as a retired
school teacher who solved crimes on
murders she wrote I thought I knew where
the treasure might be found
Lansbury lent her unique voice to
animated films including Mrs Potts in
Beauty and the Beast
normally retired I'll probably
pass away you know with one hand
one hand on my script one of the last
great stars from Hollywood's Golden Era
Angela Lansbury dead at 96.
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
candidate is Alberta's kananasca's
country we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to us and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]